thanks to Babel a language learning app
for sponsoring this episode if you're
interested in growing your language
skills microcosmos viewers get up to 60
off with a 20-day money-back guarantee
when you sign up using our Link in the
description
[Music]
the microcosmos is home to many unusual
Partnerships
their species of algae buried inside of
paramecium exchanging their
photosynthetic products for protection
there are cyanobacteria fixing nitrogen
within the glass walls of their diatom
host life is after all just
relationships individual entities
fighting and tolerating and partnering
in tiny little dramas Each of which
builds upon one another like Strokes of
paint in an epic Tableau of ecology
epidemics and yogurt
[Music]
yes yogurt that plastic tub tucked away
in the dairy section of your local
grocery store is the product of one of
the most fruitful microbial friendships
that humans have unknowingly played
Matchmaker too a friendship that goes
back Millennia that relationship is
playing out in front of your eyes right
now extracted from some yogurt that
James our master of microscopes had on
hand we don't know how exactly yogurt
was invented just that it is an ancient
food that takes on many names in
different cultures
humans began consuming Dairy somewhere
between 10 000 to 5000 BCE likely
coinciding with our domestication of
animals like cows and goats that could
provide us with milk and the challenge
those humans faced is one many of us can
relate to if you leave milk out it goes
bad quite easily in the Middle East and
Western Asia nomadic herdsmen would
carry milk in bags made from animals
that retained some of their enzymes
which may have then fermented the milk
and preserved it and over time yogurt
spread through different cultures not
just because it was effective as a milk
storage method but also because it
seemed to be quite good for the stomach
[Music]
according to one story King Francois the
first of France was suffering from
severe diarrhea to help him out his
Turkish Ally Suleiman the Magnificent
suggested yogurt bringing yogurt to the
rest of Europe at least that's one of
the stories yogurt has a surprisingly
Mythic aspect to it thanks to its
longevity popularity and cryptic Origins
and in the early 20th century one
Bulgarian scientist sought to untangle
some of the Mysteries behind yogurt his
name was stamen grigorov and in the year
1904 he was headed to the Medical
University of Geneva to study medicine
and he brought with him a clay pot
containing homemade yogurt grigorov's
work came about 50 years after Louis
Pasteur pieced together the role of
yeast and the fermentation of alcohol
but the organisms behind yogurt's genius
were still unknown and as a Bulgarian
stocked with both his homeland's yogurt
and curiosity grigorov decided it was
time to take a closer look
he found two bacteria the first was
shaped like a rod and would be named
bacillus bulgaricus in honor of its
Origins with time the species name would
be changed first two lactobacillus
bulgaricus and then to lactobacillus
delbrucci subspecies bulgaricus because
that is quite a lot to say we're gonna
stick with the slightly Incorrect and
older name lactobacillus bulgaricus
the other bacterium was rounder in shape
and it would later come to be known as
streptococcus salivarius subspecies
thermophilus though we're gonna call it
streptococcus thermophilus
lactobacillus bulgaricus and
streptococcus thermophilus may look
different from one another but what they
share in common is that they thrive on
the lactose sugars present in milk
digesting them and releasing lactic acid
back into their surroundings
as the lactic acid seeps into the milk
the milk itself becomes less hospitable
to other microbes allowing these lactic
acid bacteria to take over but if you've
ever added lemon juice to milk you're
probably familiar with the other effect
that lactic acid has it curdles the milk
the result of proteins breaking apart
but lactobacillus bulgaricus and
streptococcus thermophilus are not
simply two bacteria who happen to
coexist within the same yogurt these two
organisms work together they could
survive just fine on their own but when
they're cultured together they grow
faster thanks to a molecular exchange
between the two
lactobacillus bulgaricus offers amino
acids made by breaking down the proteins
in milk to streptococcus thermophilus
which doesn't have the tools it needs to
be able to do the same thing and in
return streptococcus thermophilus
produces various fatty acids and other
chemicals that help lactobacillus
bulgaricus grow we don't know how these
two organisms originally found each
other we're not
entirely sure how they found their way
into milk our best theory is that they
were both found on the roots of plants
that were boiled with sheep's milk by
Bulgarian Shepherds who were making
yogurt and their existence has inspired
other scientists as well shortly after
grigorov revealed the presence of
lactobacillus bulgaricus in yogurt an
immunologist named Eli mechnikov became
interested in the bacteria as well
mechnikov's work in Immunology was
influential and would go on to win him
the Nobel Prize but he was also
fascinated with aging and particularly
the idea that microbes living within us
would help us live longer microbes like
grigorov's recently discovered
lactobacillus bulgaricus in his book The
prolongation of Life optimistic studies
mechnikov described his daily probiotic
regimen he would either consume a pure
culture of the bacteria followed by milk
or he would go for the simpler option
yogurt machnikov didn't specify exactly
how he measured his satisfaction with
his experiment just that he was happy
with the results but the pathways he
thought lactobacillus bulgaricus would
follow in the body don't seem to have
been borne out in later experiments
making his specific theories about their
use as tools to help us live longer
unlikely of course that is not to say
that yogurt isn't good for you just that
its benefits are different from what
mechnikov envisioned and moreover his
work got scientists thinking about using
microbes as a sort of medicine decades
before the term probiotics was even
created and it is fitting that
lactobacillus bulgaricus would catalyze
this way of thinking a microbe in
partnership with streptococcus
thermophilus for thousands of years and
really in partnership with us even now
separated from the plants they once
lived on these bacteria cultivate our
yogurt and feed us just as they feed
each other
thank you
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and thank you again to Babel for
sponsoring this episode of Journey to
the microcosmos are you getting ready
for some summer travel and need to learn
a new language for your trip usually
trying to learn a new language requires
a lot of time and commitment making it
difficult to quickly get into
conversations well Babel is a language
learning app that helps you use a new
language in real life situations after
only five hours of practice and it
offers lessons in 14 different languages
it's the number one language learning
app in the world and with its short
interactive 10-minute lessons Babel
teaches more than just vocab words it
teaches you about the culture people
history and more associated with the
language you're learning and Babel
offers multiple ways to learn including
podcasts games and live classes so you
can choose whatever format works best
for you as a microcosmos viewer you'll
get up to 60 off when you sign up using
our link Plus Babel comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee so you can see
where Babel takes you on your language
learning Journey
before we go we'd also like to say thank
you to each and every one of our patrons
some of their names are on the screen
right now and these are the people that
make this Channel and videos like this
possible and we are so so grateful if
you'd like to become one of them you can
go to patreon.com journey to micro if
you'd like to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]